the kids in the Monti hats come across
as douchey grant it they come across as
douchey but we're all supposed to act
like this guy isn't a toothless far-left
activist instigator seemingly on an
opium Vision Quest I don't understand
leading this show with sports news from
the weekend the Patriots beat the Chiefs
so that one OK for those people who were
not followed there was a huge clash
between some kids and Maya hats and a
Native American elder yes let me answer
this question of the day finding out
what the full story is now what's
transmitted has it changed your opinion
for those who haven't been following
what will kind of fill you in in a
second so for those who are following
this this weekend this is most likely
all you saw
I could didn't even know he's being
filmed now some of this might seem
nonsensical to some people watching but
if you were on Twitter or Instagram
basically everyone covered it this way a
group of kids in Maya had surrendered
Native American veterans a veteran
specifically taunted him with chants of
build a wall until he cried that's
pretty much how it was covered there was
the outrage mob now there was the
outrage mob violence later here like you
just saw pollution right exactly
I saw a mega hat by the roadside also my
drums out of beat mess will do that so
this is a terrible sir okay okay
many on Twitter right away they started
with the outraged mob against the kids
here's the thing many conservatives
actually took the side of Nathan
Phillips a Native American elder without
waiting for the full story if you notice
one person did not react immediately
yours truly
here's what when I see this sort of
thing when I see this kind of a story I
think to myself sleep on it
well you like every other person out
there that should have you should have
learned by now that you can't just judge
what the media gives you right
especially edited clips of videos well
especially when they didn't show
anything other than people standing
there the thing is is that it's getting
to the point where you have to think
that with literally every storaged on
the news because I only saw this I was
watching the Morning News
on Sunday mm-hm and I've thought to
myself wow there's a punk kid acting
like a punk kid at a school field trip I
think he would have seen it yes the
first clip that's what they would here's
what actually happen I don't see the
clip show the picture what actually let
me kind of go point by point for people
who haven't been following point one the
Native American elder actually was the
one who initiated the confrontation not
the high school kid the kids were
already there waiting for a bus doing a
school chant one activist group the
black Israelites you know I've had my
run-ins with them can't go to heaven by
the way because because there's not
enough melanin my skin that's what they
told me they're already taunting the
kids okay there was a second group led
by nathan phillips
native american guy he approached them
got in their faces with the drums and
that's what brings you to what you're
seeing here
see how much they respect you Israel a
little confusing because usually when
someone says it's that that's that
signals peaceful intent yeah absolutely
I mean it's not like the this accosted
the students or anything but if somebody
walked up to you at this location
beating a drum and then got like in your
face well what reaction which I would
just think they were hi by the way it's
a certification they'll join mud clip so
you can see the Daily Show or subscribe
on iTunes for those who listen a show
because for some reason iTunes sometimes
they send tender berries okay
here's what we're going to say Brian's
gonna say I oh I always think of the
Colin Quinn joke of the black is
realized so the longest-running show on
Broadway yes exactly
next point three below watch the it's
funny when Colin Quinn tells it yes in
order to that your despite the initial
coverage the magna had kids they
actually never chanted build the wall no
this is really important at all so
Nathan Phillips he claimed that the
students taunted him in the media ran
with this with quote build the wall
don't take my word for it I heard I
heard M sayings build that wall
[Music]
this is indigenous lands first off I
cannot verify that that's true I assume
it's incorrect second two hours of raw
video has been released at no point do
the kids chain anything about the wall
we can't show you the full two hours
here you can see this a little learn
tons and tons of videos you can go look
it up make them look great you can go
ahead up and watch for yourself
yes we will and of course it's more
evidence emerged by the way became
increasingly clear that Native Americans
we're just looking for a bar fight we
know that now something else that nobody
covers Nathan Phelps not just some
random Native American elder he's a far
left activist who has a long-standing
history of instigating confrontation and
then claiming racial harassment and by
the way okay I know I'm about to voice a
very unpopular opinion here because no
one dared say this but I'm everyone and
I mean everyone
has been acting as though this man is a
wise sage and we should all admire him
[Music]
he's provided
is it me because the kids are the mod
hats come across as douchey granted they
come across as douchey but we're all
supposed to act like this guy isn't a
toothless far-left activist instigator
seemingly in an opium Vision Quest I
don't understand the thing is you have
to light it from the bottom and use a
torch lighter no no that BIC said my
head but really you take care of your
own you take care of your own Nathan
Phillips that's that's why that's a
typical native mr. Miyagi traditionally
named Patrick Jones yes you take care of
is that what we see rampant unemployment
and drug addiction in Native American
communities is that what Native American
high schoolers have two two possibly
three times more opioid abuse than the
rest of the population they're not
faring so well no we used to take care
of it have you been to a Native American
reservation recently does it seem like
they're thriving like it's the
neighborhood that you want to visit to
go look at Christmas lights not exactly
I would say yes gerald
it's the trainwreck of socialism in
progress right now we get to look at and
go what would socialism be like if we
provided for everybody
anything that they wanted what would
that look like look at the Native
American reservations moral care of our
own we want to tow don't get us wrong we
still want you to make it rain and Huff
Windex some I can tell you guys don't
want to go along with me on this you
guys are cowards it's reopens to
multiple ins meeting their valuable
lessons I think to be learned here so
importantly frankly these are lessons
that should have been learned a long
time ago so let's go lesson number one
sleep on it
just wait the benefit okay let's gotta
weigh the pros and cons here the risk
reward ratio the benefit of jumping on
something immediately is it maybe just
maybe you break the story slightly
earlier than the Occupy Wall Street
Facebook page but that's not worth
having egg on your face when it turns
out to be false or even worse finding
out by the way that you wrongfully
smeared someone a real person's actual
reputation which is what we run into all
yeah this is especially true whenever
there's a
I knew like anti-trump blockbuster right
always gave it 48 to 72 hours yeah
absolutely never holds up and you're
purposefully it seems like they're
purposefully ruining people's
reputations you know in journalism
you're supposed to wait until you have
some confirmation before you break a
story right if it's a huge breaking
story that you want to get out there and
people are basically doing it for a few
more likes or a few more shares or a few
more likes more to it than that which
will kind of get to in a second after
the lessons I think you're right lesson
number two I think it's really important
by the way unlike the left who defend
their own at all costs conservatives a
little too quick to cannibalize don't
jump at that and I get it we often
criticize the left for refusing to call
out their own and I think rightfully so
especially when I pal around with
pro-hitler anti-semites like Farrakhan
but too far in the other direction
conservatives are not only willing to
call out their own it seems they're
overly eager to cannibalize their own
just to prove a point don't do that
don't sacrifice someone else's
reputation just because of your desire
to appear like a reasonable conservative
trademark as I see it on Twitter because
here's something else someone can be a
dick and they can also be right for
reference say our president attacks are
working because they're making us feel
so bad about holding the viewpoints that
we have that when somebody in our camp
does something seemingly inappropriate
right oh gosh we have to like their
attacks are working they've done it so
many times right it makes us come out
against our own people when they didn't
even do anything wrong well take this
term compassion I'm a compassionate
conservative now what a second what do
you what do you mean you mean that all
of the other conservatives who believe
in equality for all and freedom of
opportunity and freedom across the board
they're not compassionate what do you
mean my support model cities oh shut up
the other thing is for all the
criticizing at the that we do towards
liberals about how quickly had to go to
outrage we go from zero to oh my god I'm
offended falling back my fainting couch
really quick I wouldn't say we I would
say watch this show from The Cosby pills
in your yeah yeah this was a lesson by
the way to Andrew Breitbart tried to
teach us the media tries to paint this
and I saw I was watching unfortunately
CNN on Sunday I do it almost every
Sunday because why I do it so that you
don't have
- you should be thanking me I just let
the dress say you know Trump tries to
paint this as though it's Trump versus
the media but certainly the media versus
Trump it's the media versus anyone on
the right and by the way it's always
been this way the idea that it started
with Trump this whole debacle it's very
similar to when um as it was a
congressman Clyburn yeah was it I think
was flying sniper to clean the tea party
protesters call John Lewis the n-word by
the way the media they played the clip
they ran the headline and you you
assumed you heard I even and I remember
this I assumed that I heard it the first
tenet ran because they showed the
congressman walking up the steps and
they and then the the Quran says called
the n-word and I want to do it tricks
you where you go home all day of course
and mother showing the clip he got mad
they wouldn't just silence the audio and
say he was called me Edward could never
do but it never happened no one ever
said the n-word just like none of these
kids none of them ever chanted build the
wall Andrew Breitbart by the way offered
to donate a hundred thousand dollars to
the Negro College Fund for evidence that
anyone said the n-word and here's what's
important about that you can go back and
watch the people who are kind of new you
know you came in with the alt-right kind
of this neutral conservative I get it
I'm glad that you guys aren't bored in
your developing but a lot of you aren't
familiar with what happened with Andrew
Breitbart they dragged his name through
the mud over this he offered a hundred
thousand dollars to the college fund for
anyone who had any evidence saying the
n-word
okay here's what matters there was more
footage than you could watch in a
lifetime of the walk up the steps and
every single angle Michael Bay couldn't
have this many cameramen on the payroll
all right and it showed the opposite no
evidence of the n-word which some could
say is evidence of the opposite yeah one
thing I remember from that time is that
was also when Democrats first started
well if you were Jewish Democrat you
happen to get a fact from someone who
had a said a Jewish slur
right and if you're Hispanic Democrat
you happen to get a fact from someone
Hispanic slur and then when Eric Cantor
pointed out if they go by the way I'm a
Republican and I've got I have Democrats
and people who are against me sending
Jewish lards towards me all of a sudden
the media didn't care right when the
Republicans like ah I've got an envelope
with white powder in it must be some
more powder cocaine for you
look the retractions that happen after
this to don't don't make any difference
whatsoever right once you say it you put
it out there everybody's like oh of
course they were yelling the n-word
people doesn't matter I mean Breitbart
did something very laudable
but ultimately how many people on the
Left said oh maybe they're right at that
point he his platform wasn't big enough
to really come out the media that was
the issue he was running up against
that's why we're so grateful for people
who joined Mudd Club and we're grateful
that we're able to be surpassing the big
leftist channels here on YouTube but if
you look at this with the Mogga hat kids
I guess is the story how it's being told
are we supposed to believe that CNN
didn't have the ability to find the full
footage to do the basic research this
same media who tells us by the way they
tell us that they're real journalists
and they go well we hate Donald Trump's
attack on the press because true
journalism not some bloggers out there
with fake news we matter and we're the
backbone of the American of the American
traditional institutions of truth really
so we're supposed to believe here that
you so there are only two options here
okay option number one either CNN and
the rest of the media are a grossly
incompetent they didn't have access to
the clips or couldn't be bothered to do
basic research why would the kind of
basic research that we do on this a
comedy show or number two they acted out
of malice they acted in malice in that
they had access to the full footage and
they ran the story as you saw it anyway
probably number two based in effect that
CNN was still pushing the story the
morning after it had already been
debunked well I would really go with
number a third option they're both I
think they're both incompetent and they
have malicious intent they have a
worldview and they're looking to push
that worldview period no matter what
evidence comes against them at all yeah
I think this is also the result of when
you get kids going to the Columbia
School of Journalism looking to be the
next Samantha bee I was going to say Jon
Stewart but I'm actually a fan of his
comedy but um yeah no but the thing is
is that they're they're attacking these
stories not from looking for a place the
truth they're attacking it from a place
of we hate Donald Trump right so the
normal vetting that would go into like
checking to see if these were accurate
likes like I don't think is just who the
Donald Trump I mean I remember dan
Rather it's working with the documents
with oh yeah so I didn't like this for
the right I think it's definitely been
worth with Donald Trump wait they're not
even pretending because because he's not
silently and denied because Trump is
calling them out Gordon I don't think
and I know you were not a big fan of
present Drummond I certainly wasn't the
primaries but I will say this at this
moment in time I don't think that any
other candidate had they become
president would have showcased have
highlighted the media for their
dishonest I like you I think he's a very
easily thing right they blame Donald
Trump for the division he is a result of
the division that they created or at
least in part right there part of it
created Donald Trump if they're pissed
at anybody for Donald Trump being
president they need only look at
themselves right yeah you do this enough
what's a Lamar kid in the Native
American story and you say look at this
and then what you end up with you say
what do you think about Cortes and downs
with us who cares that's what happens
yeah who cares screw you yeah but you
said the Baca can attack the old the old
[ __ ] so I don't care what you have to
say that's what happens yes we should be
reasonable okay we shouldn't have a herd
mentality of disagreeing with our
opponents just for the sake of
disagreement but compromising just for
compromising SiC is just as shameful you
don't become this is what bothers me
when you see the Conservatives
cannibalizing themselves you don't all
of a sudden become reasonable by
randomly agreeing with the left every
once in a while but like now I'll throw
them a bone because the kid at a douchey
had that's what happened here men when
the right forgot that the media is
waging a war against us they wanted to
appear reasonable they wanted to appear
even hand it as opposed to looking for
truth so they sided against these high
school kids who did nothing but really
stand and smile
honestly I get it I get it privileged
white kids Roscoe state than wearing a
mug a hat and he has a shit-eating grin
so we're supposed understand that but
the truth is this really isn't all that
different from any kind of a civil
rights protest where they say don't be
violent just stand and smile if you were
if the Native America are holding a
rifle and he were putting a daisy in
there it would be an iconic picture well
let me not for him because he's white
right no exactly any just get run over
with a tank by the way this of course
opened the floodgates to countless
articles people who don't want to talk
about this the Conservatives who virtu
signaled and said I can't believe these
kids they should be ashamed themselves
it opened the floodgates to countless
articles about the school being LGBT
being against LGBTQ AI people just
reading on Huffington Post this morning
how they need to be shut down and by
proxy the Pence's being evil super
villains you get the point
so remember the lessons here if you see
a controversial news story
okay sleep on it be skeptical and don't
crucify one of your own in a panic over
the meeting especially not publicly
that's what's really important wait for
the evidence and remember when it comes
to truth when it comes to the access to
information right now don't forget we
are absolutely in a war we are at war
remember that we have edgy styles coming
up after the break hey there YouTube
viewer if you like this video I would
say subscribe hit the notification bell
or watch one of these videos playing in
a box that we've personally uploaded in
program for your viewing pleasure
the problem is now in today's day and
age on YouTube in 2018 any of those
three things that you do any of those
three buttons that you click will take
you directly to a Seth Meyers video so
stay here and join my get off of here go
to a lot of credit accounts like my club
it's the only safe place you can go
enjoy